the smoke has cleared and both Iran and
the United States have signaled plans to
deescalate tensions after we killed
their top general and they lobbed some
missiles into the dirt we take a look at
the key lessons from the best war ever
then cardi B fears for her safety and
Trump's America so she's planning on
moving to Nigeria Joy Behar endorses
white supremacist Richard Spencer on the
view and Prince Harry quits his own
family proving once again that you
should never marry a feminist finally
the mailbag all that more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
all right we have got a lot to get to
today so we're gonna fly right through
it
I'm sure everyone has heard or seen
snippets of at least president from
statement yesterday he gave a statement
on the tensions with Iran overall it was
a superb statement we don't need to
watch the whole thing
in your own time listen to it it was
really really good I mean it was just I
I dare say it was a flawless statement
he tripped over a few words so it wasn't
technically flawless but in terms of the
strategy that was being conveyed it was
just perfect
Trump pointed out that sulemani was a
dirtbag who had to die he pointed out
that no Americans were injured in the
retaliation from Iran he said that
America was going to reinstitute
sanctions
Ilhan omar and some other radicals in
the Democratic Party were very upset by
this but that's par for the course by
saying he was going to reinstitute the
sanctions this was a de-escalation
obviously just as Iran said that in
order to save face they had to respond
to the killing of sulemani so - the
United States has to respond to the
ballistic missiles that were shot at our
base even though nobody was killed thank
God still that response of the sanctions
is a de-escalation is very smart and
then Trump reminded the mullahs and he
reminded all the other dirtbags around
the world that the United States has a
bigger button than they do and that our
missiles work I mean this is basically
the Trump doctrine is the bigger button
doctrine you could call it the Reagan
doctrine in many ways which is peace
through strength and he also got in a
good knock on Barack Obama in the
previous administration here just a
short clip from the speech where
President Trump explains how we got into
this mess and how he's cleaning up what
Obama started Iran's hostilities
substantially increased after the
foolish Iran nuclear deal was signed in
2013 and they were given one hundred and
fifty billion dollars not to mention 1.8
billion dollars in cash
instead of saying thank you to the
United States they chanted death to
America
in fact they chanted death to America
the day the agreement was signed then
Iran went on a terror spree funded by
the money from the deal and created hell
in Yemen Syria Lebanon Afghanistan and
Iraq the missiles fired last night at us
and our allies were paid for with the
funds made available by the last
administration right
the missiles were funded with the money
sent over by Barack Obama to Iran that
is a very politically evocative way to
look at the situation it also happens to
be correct people are saying that this
is gratuitous that he didn't need to
take the shot at Obama here yes he did
it was one of the most important aspects
of the whole statement because we have
to ask ourselves how did we get here how
did we get to the precipice of war with
Iran the left is trying to blame Trump
it isn't Trump's fault the way we got to
the precipice of war with Iran is not
because we showed some strength and
killed their general killing their
general was a response to acts of war
that Iran was already foisting upon us
including the attack on the Baghdad
embassy including the killing of an
American contractor just a couple weeks
ago including hundreds of American
deaths at the hands of sulamani in the
region how did we get here
the answer is the feckless policies in
part brought about by Barack Obama and
for those saying that Trump shouldn't
blame Obama for everything
Obama blamed Bush for every little thing
that happened during his presidency his
completely failed economic recovery the
political obstruction the wars in the
Middle East many of which he started
Obama started he would just blame Bush
for everything of no president in my
lifetime has liked blaming the past
administration as much as Obama possibly
until Trump because he learned a page at
a barack obama's playbook trump here is
rightly pointing out that he is solving
the problems brought on by bra
Obama and Obama and his administration
by the way didn't he just leave it at
blaming Bush and then failing throughout
their eight years they have been
undermining Trump's campaign and then
presidency from the very beginning they
spied on him to begin with they tried to
cheat the 2016 election and then ever
since he got into power they have
they've actually been calling foreign
powers they've been calling Iran to try
to undermine Trump's Iran strategy so
Trump comes into office and he says
we're gonna rip up that crappy Iran deal
and we're gonna negotiate our own deal
and John Kerry Obama's Secretary of
State gets on the phone with javad zarif
who's the foreign minister of Iran and
he gets on the phone he says Siobhan I'm
so sorry honey honey monkey please
lovey-dovey he always sounds like
Thurston Howell the third at whenever I
see him speaking he kind of looks like I
don't know Frankenstein or something or
a Herman Munster he's just there this
throws and waspy the politician trying
to cling to whatever power is still left
and he says Siobhan please we'll work it
out don't don't let this deal fall apart
because this is the Obama legacy in Iran
is that Iran deal and look at what the
legacy has led to American deaths an
attack on our embassy fecklessness and a
complete absence of deterrence president
Trump reinstituted that this has worked
out perfectly I was just recounting
yesterday the victories of this
administration where this is the cherry
on top of the sundae we'll get to that
in a second then we'll get to the very
important news of course which is cardi
B but first let's face it most New
Year's resolutions are hard to keep get
more exercise save more money there is a
resolution however that is easy to keep
stop wasting time going to the post
office use stamps calm instead I love
stamps calm they've been with us almost
since the very beginning with stamps
calm you can do everything that you do
at the post office right from your
computer and I will tell you as a
millennial I I I go to the post office
like twice a year maybe I can't bring
myself to do it because in every other
aspect of our lives we
use our computers we can use our phones
to get these kind of basic things done
and yet some people just haven't adapted
quickly that's where stamps.com comes in
because stamps.com is bringing the post
office to your house big discounts on
postage by the way so stamps calm you
get every service of the US Postal
Service at your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices whether
you're an online seller shipping out
products maybe you're a warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps comm can handle it all with ease
we here at the daily wire love it simply
use your computer print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you can do
that to day no risk whatsoever with my
promo code Knolls KO wles
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long term commitments
or contracts go to stamps.com then click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Noel's scam wles
stamp stack-on promo code an old scanner
wles go do it right now you will thank
me later stamps comm never go to the
post office again after this moment this
this precipice on the brink of war
people say there's World War three a
bunch of ignorant Millennials and
Zoomers saying that they're gonna
reinstitute the draft or something we
have another draft in this country in
decades
Trump strikes back and causes Iran to
blink causes Iran to back down and then
we de-escalate the tensions right now
javad zarif John Kerry's buddy says that
there is not going to be a further
response and Trump is pulling back now
and it looks like we've avoided the war
or maybe we've already had the war and
it was the best war ever because no
Americans died in that war I was going
through the math I thought booming
economy record low unemployment record
high consumer confidence Manufacturing
confidence the leader of Isis dead at
the top military General in Iran dead
deterrence reinstituted record
deregulation 187 judges two of whom are
on the Supreme Court
solid judges who will have a legacy
longer than the Trump administration the
list goes on and on and on you have to
admit it we all have to admit it to
ourselves even those who were skeptical
of Trump even those people on the left
maybe who hate Trump's character you
have to admit the man is an excellent
president he's doing a great job the
handling of this Iran issue from the
Baghdad attack embassy attack before
that the response was it was flawless it
couldn't possibly have gone any better
no American casualties as we stand up to
Iran as we take out one of the most
important men in their country and one
of the most important men to global
terrorism and no American casualties is
the response to that because we've now
reestablished the credible threat of
violence and we've we've maintained
president Trump's unpredictability one
of the most important advantages you can
have in foreign affairs
he's doing a great job and if you're one
of these people on the left writer
Center who are still laboring under this
misapprehension the Trump is some
bumbling idiot who just accidentally
seems to get all these things right he's
just that bumbling fool billionaire who
married a supermodel who succeeded in
network television and real estate and
casinos and politics got the biggest job
in the world on his first dry if you
still think that you've probably got the
wrong idea you're probably looking at
this a little wrong presidents have
always hadn't the advantage the
successful presidents have always had
the advantage of being underestimated it
was true of that's certainly true of
Trump it was true of George W Bush it
was true Bill Clinton right George Bush
he was a total idiot
Bill Clinton he's just a nice guy from
Arkansas it was true of Ronald Reagan
he's just a dumb actor he's just the guy
who did bedtime for Bonzo
they've always been underestimated and
then and then they succeed you know
Reagan takes down the Soviet Union takes
down the Berlin wall all the way fast
forward to President Trump who wins this
incredibly complex conflict with Iran
with zero American casualties
a wonderful thing the guy deserves
credit for it Trump also called this in
the 80s a lot of people don't remember
it but he in the 1980s when he was
beginning to dip his toe into politics
set the stage for his political career
he took out massive ads in newspapers in
New York Times bunch of other newspapers
actually criticizing the Reagan
administration something tells me that
no matter who was president at the time
if Trump wanted to establish the basis
for his political career he would have
attacked them all in the same way but he
criticized Reagan for not being strong
enough on foreign affairs and we said
was there is nothing about our foreign
defense policy that can't be fixed with
a little backbone now Ronald Reagan did
take down the Soviet Union so I think he
had some backbone but the the general
principle is correct because when you
look at President Trump's foreign policy
he's not fundamentally reordering the
world order right he's not fundamentally
reordering American foreign affairs he
isn't actually dismantling NATO or
relying with people that we don't alaih
with and betraying our allies and
cozying up to our enemies he's not
actually doing that I know the
mainstream media says so but look around
it all basically looks the same the
difference is the backbone the
difference is when you draw a red line
you actually back it up the difference
is deterrence and it's so simple I was
talking to a friend of mine very
prominent in foreign policy who said all
these academics all these intellectuals
they make foreign policy so much more
complicated than it should be
actually the key to foreign policy is
that it's very simple be good to our
allies and crush our enemies it's simple
enough don't you know you don't need to
make it more complicated
I think that's Trump's view of it and it
happens to be correct a Medal of Honor
recipient at the White House earlier
this week summed up the approach it was
a beautiful beautiful simple explanation
of our foreign policy we'll get to that
in a second then of course what I
promise you we're gonna get to the most
important news I know you're on the edge
of your seat cuz cardi B is gonna move
to Nigeria and the royal family is is
breaking up prince areas doing this and
it's all the fault of one American
actress but first I'm gonna thank our
friends over at quip
quip the makers of the equip electric
toothbrush want you to know that there
is a single discovery that matters most
for your dental care and is simply this
if you have good habits you're good good
habits that's what it's about it's not
that you need this one simple trick that
you do one so then you're gonna have
great teeth no you need good habits this
is true in every realm of life
Aristotle describes virtues as habits
you got to practice them okay and when
it comes to your teeth that means
brushing for two minutes twice a day and
flossing regularly doesn't matter what
brand you use okay you just got to do it
quick makes that so simple starting with
an electric toothbrush refillable floss
and anti cavity toothpaste quips
electric brush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean the quip floss dispenser
comes with pre marked string to help you
use just enough
it is good habits that is what you are
getting
quick delivers fresh brush head floss
and toothpaste refills to your door
every three months with free shipping so
your routine is always right if you're
like me you you know you wait until
there's like one micro millimeter of
toothpaste left in the tube and you're
squeezing it out and it's all this kind
of origami that you're doing with it
don't worry about that okay you don't
need to try to live like that you don't
need to make it all the way to the store
like quit make this easy for you starts
at 25 bucks if you go to get quick calm
slash michael mi CH AE l right now you
will get your first refill free merry
christmas that is your first refill free
and get quipped Karm slash michael GE t
qu IP calm slash michael quip the good
habits companies so Staff Sergeant David
Bellavia was receiving the Medal of
Honor earlier this week and obviously
there were tensions building with Iran
he explained the Trump doctrine he
explained the kind of basic fundamentals
of American foreign policy very well be
good to our friends be bad to our
enemies we don't want war but if if you
ask for war we'll crush you our military
should not be mistaken for a cable news
gabfest show we don't care what you look
like we don't care who you voted for who
you worship what you worship who you
love
it doesn't matter if your dad left you
millions when he died or if he knew who
your father was
we have been honed into a machine of
lethal moving parts that you would be
wise to avoid if you know what's good
for you we will not be intimidated we
will not back down we've seen war we
don't want war but if you want war with
the United States of America there's one
thing I could promise you so help me God
someone else will raise your sons and
daughters simple enough Jim mattis as a
famous quote he was speaking to some
officers in Iraq some of the officers
who could be our allies or could be our
enemies and he said to them look I'm
pleading with you I am begging from the
bottom of my heart do not betray us
because I want to work together I want
to be friends with you but if you betray
us I will kill every last one of you
that is sort of the American foreign
policy fundamental that's the Trump
doctrine is we do not want war we don't
want it democracy's republic's we tend
to hate war okay we're fickle and there
are elections every few years and we
just don't want war however if you
provoke us if you demand war if you
force war on us we will kill every last
one of you we will make sure that other
people raise your children okay that was
what Trump told the mullahs in Iran and
they listened in their response to us
killing one of the most important guys
in their country was to lob a bunch of
missiles into the dirt well done then
we're gonna impose sanctions we
deescalate because America has strength
now not everybody is thrilled Trump I'm
sorry to say has lost a key voting
demographic he has lost the cardi B vote
who is cardi B I don't really know I
guess she's a figure of music or
something she's a really funny character
I really like her as a cultural figure
she she's now become kind of a Bernie
bro but previously she had this video go
out where she realized how much money
the federal government was taking out of
her paychecks and she was just I
rate it was it was this beautiful moment
because it was like looking almost at a
child and like a 16 year old kid gets
their first paycheck and says wait
where'd all my money go and she she
famously said what y'all doing with my
mother f and money I want receipts I
want receipts what y'all doing with my
mother F and money so ironically then
because she probably hasn't thought too
deeply about politics she's now become a
Bernie bro Bernie who wants to take all
of her money every last penny but with
regard to Iran cardi B just tweets out
nah these memes are effing and then a
few emojis so like all the memes about
World War 3 like they're funny and
they're sad and they're terrifying but
Shi T ain't no joke especially being
from New York it said this man is
putting Americans lives in danger
dumbest move Trump did till date I'm
filing for my Nigerian citizenship so
first of all Trump just staved off war
more Americans were killed by Iran in
the weeks before we killed sulamani
then in the whole retaliation after we
killed sulemani so this idea that
American weakness is how you get peace
has been disproven all right we just it
was disproven two days ago however I
want to get to the Nigerian citizenship
part because I don't know that cardi B
has ever googled Nigeria Nigeria has
three times the murder rate of the
United States 50% more crime overall 27
percent of women in Nigeria suffer
female genital mutilation one in four
girls and one in ten boys will
experience sexual violence before the
age of 18 and thirty one point four
percent of girls will report that their
first sexual encounter was rape Nigeria
is not a safe place it's not a
particularly pleasant place the United
States of America much safer much more
pleasant this is what happens this is
the effect of Trump derangement syndrome
okay this is TDs in action is people
especially on the left gets so wrapped
up in the eccentricities of Trump in the
quirks of his personality that they
begin to think patently absurd things
like we will be safer in Nigeria than we
are in the United States look no further
for this you want to see the perfect the
prime example of Trump derangement
syndrome look at the ladies on the view
on the view yesterday
Joy Behar who's kind of the central
leftist woman on the view she literally
sits in the center of the table and
she's the main leftist there she was so
happy because Richard Spencer the white
supremacist is furious at Trump that
Trump is standing up to Iran she didn't
even think through the implications of
her excitement which is that Joy Behar
is now on the same side as Richard
Spencer and they don't just accidentally
fall on the same side or coincidentally
they're on the same side of the same
policy question for the same policy
reasons Mamie that would cause a
rational person to rethink their own
views on the policy not Joy Behar she's
just so happy that anybody including a
white supremacist opposes Trump it was
one small thing he was saying what's
some good news this is it's a tiny thing
that I noticed you remember Richard
Spencer he's basically the organizer of
unite Narayan attack the white
nationalist group that was marching in
Charlottesville it's all in for Trump
not anymore
his his quote he tweeted last night I
deeply regret voting for and promoting
Donald Trump in 2016 oh my gosh ran are
not invading and not being oh I love it
I love the applause because we have some
good news we won another person over to
our cause we're on the same side as
Richard Spencer
oh yeah we're on the same side it's that
white supremacist guy woohoo if she had
stopped to think about this for two
seconds she would say wait a second if
Richard Spencer opposes Trump and I
opposed Trump and if Richard Spencer
poses showing strength to iran and i
oppose showing strength to iran that
means that i'm on the same side as
richard Spencer that's that's probably
not a good look maybe I should be on the
same side as Donald Trump Oh whoops
that's not great it wasn't just Joy
Behar I would say the key here is
obviously the Trump derangement syndrome
the key is taking a moment to think
about the implications of your policy
views okay I'm not saying that you now
Joy Behar needs to support Trump I'm not
saying I'm saying she needs to stop take
a beat hold on a second and realize the
implications of what she's saying
Ilhan omar did exactly the same thing
yesterday Ilhan Omar member of the squad
she came out and said even from
sanctions on Iran are unacceptable we
can't sanction Iran because quote
sanctions are economic warfare sanctions
cause death and starvation and disease
sanctions are terrible right okay what
she failed to remember is that a year
ago
Ilhan Omar explicitly called for
sanctions of Israel so by admitting that
sanctions are economic warfare and they
cause death and destruction and mayhem
what she's saying is we can never engage
in war with Iran even if Iran is killing
our servicemen to the tune of over 600
even if Iran kills a contractor an
American contractor just a couple weeks
ago even if Iran attacks our embassy
even if Iran lobs ballistic missiles at
US bases we can never engage in that
kind of warfare with Iran also let's
declare war on Israel because why why
what an Israel do to us I have a few
suspicions of why Ilhan Omar wants to
declare war on Israel but she I'm not
even saying she needs to all of a sudden
like Israel and hate Iran I'm just
saying if she weren't so warped it was
so wrapped up by this trump derangement
syndrome just like Joy Behar just like
most of the American left she wouldn't
probably
they take a moment to think through the
implications of what she's saying and
maybe she wouldn't say it etiology makes
people crazy you know what else makes
people crazy a specific ideology called
feminism and Prince Harry has just
learned that lesson as has the entire
United Kingdom pretty breaking news if
we weren't just recovering from the best
war ever if we weren't just cooling off
from the brink of tensions with Iran
this would have been the biggest news
story of the day the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex so Prince Harry and his wife the
American actress Megan Markel issued a
statement yesterday that they are
quitting the royal family I know it
seems bizarre to quit your own family
but when you're a royal the family is
the job and they are quitting both their
family and the job of being a royal the
reason they're doing this is to become
financially independent which if you're
reading between the lines means Megan
Markel wants to be in some movies again
you know most girls grow up they say oh
gosh I just want to be a princess oh I
want a prince charming to come up and
marry me and then well be a princess
right and that's obviously megan merkel
said that she married a prince and then
she said actually i want to be an
actress
now that's better to be an actress let
me tell you something I've worked in
Hollywood or worked in in that
particular industry it would be better
to be a royal yeah I think she's going
to come to regret this decision they
wrote what after many months of
reflection and internal discussions
we've chosen to make a transition this
year in starting to carve out a
progressive new role within this
institution we intend to step back as
senior members of the royal family and
work to become financially independent
while continuing to fully support Her
Majesty the Queen is with your
encouragement particularly over the last
few years that we feel prepared to make
this adjustment you might as well call
Harry Prince Edward the ninth he's just
like his great uncle Prince King Edward
the eighth who abdicated the throne
caused mayhem in Great Britain because
he fell in love with a divorced American
just like Megan Markel this is very bad
I mean first of all why why do we care
there's a certain American view which is
that I haven't cared about the royal
since 1776
bang-bang you know but I don't think
that's fair
the royal
family in Great Britain is currently a
pillar of Western civilization I mean
it's one of the few stabilizing forces
that we still have in this torrent of
change throughout the West and it shows
you something that's so awful about our
modern individualistic liberal culture
which is we have no sense of duty you
know we look at politics primarily
through this liberal lens which is
through the lens of rights and
entitlement
mimimi I get to do whatever I want I
shouldn't have to have any duty I should
be able to choose whatever I want to
choose and that is not in any way a
conservative vision of politics the
conservative vision looks at politics
primarily through duty through bonds of
loyalty through bonds of friendship and
kinship Prince Harry he didn't choose
his life he was born a royal that comes
with many privileges all the money all
the luxury all the palaces all the
castles all of the fame all of the
fortune right it also comes with
responsibility because your whole life
is dedicated to the public service you
are the beating heart of the nation in
the United Kingdom
you are a pillar of stability you engage
in public functions you receive foreign
dignitaries you engage in philanthropy
right that's the job it's a it's a heavy
weight to wear the crown queen elizabeth
has embodied this beautifully you don't
get to go out and do whatever you want
all the time your life is scrutinized
you have to live a virtuous life so many
Royals have failed at that Queen
Elizabeth is has really done a very good
job of showing that kind of vision of
duty and Prince Harry is is just giving
it all up because me me me and actually
his wife deserves more blame here Megan
Markell because she chose this I mean
she chose to marry a royal she got this
multi-million dollar wedding at public
expense in the United Kingdom and then
she broke up the British royal family
and she dragged her husband away because
she doesn't like it because she doesn't
want to accept the responsibility of
being a royal she likes the perks she
likes the royal wedding
likes all the fame and notoriety
obviously she does she was an actress
but she doesn't like the duty the
responsibility the idea that you have to
serve somebody else and now your life is
no longer just your own choices I mean I
know a lot of actors and actresses a lot
of people in show business they tend to
be selfish people that's just the way
this industry works you can't be selfish
if you want to be a good royal and it
just teaches you this lesson one of the
most important lessons for anyone
writing into the mailbag you know which
is never marry a feminist just don't do
it don't marry a male feminist don't
marry a female feminist it's a it's a
bad idea G it's a bad idea G in part
because it it views politics primarily
through the lens of Rights and
entitlement and me me me and I get
whatever I want regardless of certain
biological facts and regardless of the
sort of social facts that we see in the
royal family we have a role to play men
have a role to play women have a role to
play the princess a role to play the
princess has a role to play they're just
turning it's very sad I mean in some
ways it's good because you're getting
these giant radical leftists out of the
royal family but it's it's a sad thing
for Great Britain obviously we Americans
can look at this with a little bit more
distance because they're not our royal
family but it's sad done the less it
said for our politics and what it says
about the West before we get to the
mailbag I have got to get to how lame
Elizabeth Warren is I just very quickly
Elizabeth Warren you know she does these
painfully awkward social media
experiments where she goes and she
pretends to drink a beer it's like a
first time she's ever sipped beer
then she awkwardly hugs her husband and
she goes on with the Queer Eye for the
straight guy character and it's just so
stiff and awkward and she's trying to
relate to people
she just outdid herself Elle magazine
did an interview with Elizabeth Warren
where they want Liz Warren to give
advice and the whole premise is Liz
Warren's got a plan for everything and
so she's got a plan even for your
questions to Elle magazine here's just a
little clip hi I'm Elizabeth Warren and
I'm running for president of the United
States
I'm here with Elle to solve your
problems because if you haven't heard
I have a plan for that but uh oh my gosh
how weak and lame and awkward so look
and that's par for the course that's how
all these go she gets asked these
questions a woman says hey this guy that
I'm dating he's not texting me back what
should I do she says dump the guy you
know and she said another person writes
and says hey I want to get a dog my
roommate doesn't want a dog who cares I
could you imagine if Trump did this be
so pathetic this is so pathetic
Elizabeth Warren is a Harvard professor
be who you are just say who you are
you're trying to be President you're not
gonna be a gal pal you're not gonna be
this cool relatable person just be who
you are Trump knows this that's why you
want same thing with Reagan anyway they
asked her all these questions and she
gives these individual answers but when
she tweeted out the link she brought
them all together as though it were just
one question in one answer and I mention
it because she's pretty much summed up
leftism here the tweet says you deserve
better dump the guy who ghosted you
convinced the roommate to let you adopt
a dog and I'll take care of you by
canceling your student loan debt that's
it that's left ism
dump your boyfriend don't get married
stay alone forever get a dog that's fine
and just rely on me the state me me me
I'll give you money I'm your best friend
Obama did this during the 2012 campaign
he had the life of Julia cradle-to-grave
it was an explanation of how the
government will take care of you and you
don't need anybody else at no point in
the life of Julia does she fall in love
or get married or start a family or get
involved in her community
no the only meaningful relationship she
has is with the state and that's what it
Elizabeth Warren wants you to have too
and that is not only lame and awkward
and stiff and creepy it's also
politically disastrous it would be
disastrous for our politics it would be
disastrous for our spirits and our own
humanity that's Liz were all right we'll
get to the mailbag so that I can give
you the real answers that Liz Warren did
not give you you know Liz Warren has a
plan for that
I don't but I'll just give you a
straight answer so come on back for the
mailbag go to Daly wire.com you know
what you get
me then through Matt you get another
Kingdom you get the leftist ears tumblr
most importantly and you get to ask
questions in the mailbag which is coming
up in just a second
all right from Cory hey Michael how do I
get over my fear of public speaking I am
the best man at my brother's wedding and
it's a lot of pressure to deliver a good
speech as public speaking ever been an
issue for you growing up or in your
career I obviously have spoken in public
a lot your first consideration as a best
man should not be how you're going to
deliver this great oration don't worry
about the public speaking first you've
got a mistake in here that if you fix
this it'll really help you you said I've
got a lot of pressure on me to deliver a
good speech you're not going to deliver
a speech do not deliver a speech you are
a best man you are delivering a toast a
speech is the Gettysburg Address a
speech is Pericles his funeral oration a
toast is one minute long and it wishes
the groom and the bride well and then
you sit down I have seen so many bad
best man speeches I've seen worse maid
of honor speeches but I've seen most
best man speeches I've seen have been
terrible because their speeches give a
toast a speech is from you it's full
it's big it's long it's giant a toast is
hey all the best to these wonderful
people when you write your toast
keep it short at the most two to three
minutes if it's closer to one to two
minutes it will be better write it all
out that's fine and then once you write
it all out go through and take out 80%
of the first person personal pronouns I
me my get out most of them this is not
about you here's the bad version of a
best man toast
hey all right hey buddy so you remember
look I've known Johnny for about 10
years now and the one thing I noticed
about Johnny the thing that Johnny
really meant to me is we would go out
drinking a lot in college make a lot of
mistakes you remember all those girls
you dragged home I actually didn't even
think you
settle for a good girl you know but you
did you did you know I love you Jenny
anyway look you you're great and you
just mean so much to me and I want the
best for you and I think we're still
gonna have fun so anyway happy wedding
now though that's the kind of typical
best man speech
the typical maid of honor speech is even
worse because it's it's like the typical
maid of honor speech is something like
this hey Jenny you remember when the Phi
Beta Sigma girls would go out yeah well
look John when you marry one Phi Beta
Sigma girl you marry all the Phi Beta
Sigma girls anyway you're so you're my
best friend I love you so much I really
think this is so great I really loved
when we hung out and I really love being
here and I me me my I me me mine it
becomes a George Harrison song don't do
that very simple why were you chosen to
be the best man because this couple
loves you you have a wonderful
relationship with them there is some
real intimacy there so you have some
insight into them make the toast about
them do not get digs in we all we all
because we feel awkward in these toasts
we want to kind of rhythm and jasm
because that's the way that especially
men relate to one another don't do it
don't don't
it just always looks lame and petty and
people on their wedding day want nice
things they want beauty they want love
around them they want gratitude just do
that if you keep it simple if you make
it about the couple if you make it a
genuine toast if you make it a genuine
honor of the couple and if you get
yourself mostly out of it you will give
a best man toast better than 99.9
percent of them from Nicholas dear
renowned and austere religious podcaster
dr. Kofi Fey
thank you for using my title and slayer
of lives Michael Knowles thank you for
using my other title I have an issue in
the last year I've fallen madly in love
with a fantastic young woman the issue
with that is that dating and marriage
isn't in her life plan of joining the
Navy and working for the CIA and or some
such things that are over my head my
grand plan is truckin she is one of my
best friends and I
want to ruin that friendship by telling
her how I feel should I remain contempt
in him having an amazing friend or go
for broke and lay it on the table you
don't have a friend at the moment I mean
yes you you hang out and you spend time
together what you really have is a love
interest
she might have a friend but you have a
love interest so get that out of your
head of well maybe we'll just remain
platonic friends and that's right no
you're both single people you obviously
you say you're falling madly in love
with her so that's not no longer a
possibility you've only got one life
guys so go get the girl
now if you have completely different
visions of your lives one of you is
gonna have to change that vision so if
you were to get married and she's gonna
go join the Navy then you're gonna have
to be able to move around with her and
you'll be a sort of military husband if
you're gonna get married you want to be
a trucker and you're just dead set on
being a trucker and that's not gonna
work if she's moving around all the time
then she's gonna have to give up what
she wants there's going to have to be
some kind of some kind of give here but
if she's really the love of your life as
you seem to think that she is then try
to win her over now when you try to win
her over
don't be weird and sappy about it okay
this is a mistake that especially young
guys make all the time because really
when they're pursuing a woman they're
making it all about them themselves
don't make it about themselves make it
about the woman be crafty here you've
got to be innocent as a dove and wise as
a serpent so instead of going out and
saying oh Jenny I just love you so much
and I kept sorry I have to spill my my
guts here I just please you're all I
think about you're all I dream about now
don't any woman is gonna say like ah
gross
get out of here but you could say hey
let's let's go get a drink this weekend
you know when you go get a drink you say
hey it's a lovely dress you're wearing
oh thanks thanks Johnny yeah I know
problem Jenny yeah that's really cool
look at that
well anyway okay yeah we'll have another
round please okay so what are you
thinking about this summer what are you
thinking about your career
what are you thinking about this engage
with her get her thoughts on what she's
interested in and then make it clear
slowly and deliberately and confidently
that you like her present yourself as a
man that she would fall in love with -
and all that requires is a little bit of
confidence a little bit of directness
and a little seriousness serious in
purpose and light and funny in
conversation now I have seen very ugly
guys guys with no prospects guys weren't
that smart I mean guys that you would
say on paper not the best catch end up
with very beautiful women very great
women confidence is the key all right
seriously that confidence and
seriousness taking her seriously and
having a little levity and a little
humor in the conversation go for it go
kiss the girl come on
from golda dear mr. Noles can men and
women just be friends without developing
romantic feelings toward the other thank
you for all that you do yes of course
they can I got plenty of female friends
and I hope that my female friends have a
male friend in me and other people
however there are parameters here there
are some limitations so two married
people a married man and a married woman
can be friends with one another right
there's no prospect and you have to not
be willing to cheat on your spouse so
there's no prospect of any romantic
involvement those kind of people can be
friends or a man can be friends with a
woman that he doesn't find attractive or
vice versa a woman can be friends with a
man that she doesn't find attractive
though that can get dicey because if
you're both single then there might be
some unrequited feelings here or there
it can happen it is not the rule because
men and women are made to be attracted
to one another but it certainly can't
happen and you know some of my great
friends of my life are women and so you
should embrace that when you can but be
careful because you don't want to find
yourself in a bad situation where
there's unrequited love or you're
cheating on your spouse or something
like that from Blake dear master of
daily wires intrigue and force I was
wondering if there were any ways we
could convince the left to support our
efforts to sanction Iran do you know of
any laws in Iran that limit the rights
of LGBTQ citizens maybe Iran has some
strict gendered bathroom rules or
something that they've concealed from
the left surely if we can only uncover
laws like that we could find some common
ground Thanks
no it doesn't matter they know that they
know that they push gays off of roofs in
Iran and throughout the Muslim world
they they know that it's not that they
love Iran it's not that they love these
sort of countries and cultures that
fundamentally disagree with their own
ideology it's that they hate the West
it's that left ism or progressivism
is essentially an attack on Western
tradition it's progressivism right
they're trying to run away from the
tradition that that we currently have so
anybody who opposes that Western
tradition they are going to cozy up to
the enemy of my enemy is my friend and
there's no Iranian law you're gonna find
that is going to change that from Nick
dear austere religious podcaster aka the
michael knowles who would win in a fight
between you and shapiro Andrew Klavan
Matt Walsh and the God came the rules
would be the only weapons allowed would
be tumblers and the published books of
whoever wields them also mandatory ad
breaks every five minutes for zip
recruiter who would win ah that last
part is what throws me off because if it
were just the published books of whoever
wields them then obviously I would win
because I believe my best-selling blank
magnum opus reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide has
outsold all of those guys with their
books with words so I would win in that
case however once you add in the zip
recruiter ads then it just becomes a
fight between Ben and Jeremy because Ben
and Jeremy can wield the zip recruiter
to fire me and hire somebody else to
take my show so that's the the trick
there and then Ben and Jeremy would have
to duke it out and I don't want to get
him to predicting who wins that all
right one more question from Michael
because I like that name dear Michael of
the camp Noel's the most revered an
austere religious podcaster there is a
lot of debate about whether our country
is endemic
one or a republic as far as I can tell
the only difference is representation
and a charter in its core can you please
explain what the difference is between
the democratic country and republic
thanks in advance yes it is in many ways
a question of degree direct democracy is
where every citizen is participating
directly in the lawmaking process an
indirect democracy veering toward what
we would call a republic is when we
elect representatives to make our laws
for us and to govern ourselves for us
the trouble that has happened in our
country is that the our founders set up
a republic but over time it has become
much closer to a democracy this is the
natural inclination of representative
governments this is the natural
inclination of rule by the people our
founders knew this and our founders fear
to this if we've made democracy into a
byword for good or wonderful or the way
things should be and so anytime
something that's more democratic we all
cheer it on but there are perils of
democracy you know in a democracy you
don't have constitutional protections
and a pure democracy it's just the will
of the majority that's all that matters
and it runs roughshod over the rights of
minorities and certainly over the rights
of the smallest minority of all which is
the individual we have become more
democratic over time that's in the
nature of these representative
government's it probably means that all
things must die even including this
wonderful experiment and government that
we have but we can try to protect it
today by preserving that Republic by by
keeping what Benjamin Franklin is
reported to have said at the
Constitutional Convention a republic if
you can keep it right by preserving
those institutions and that means
thinking a little more seriously about
our politics then woo democracy now
everybody gets exactly the same thing
all the time we like pretty much Liz
Warren dancing around to music and to
empty slogans such as that it's on us we
have to do our best to educate our
fellow citizens and we got to preserve
it at the ballot box that's our show I'm
Michael no this is the Michael Nolt show
see how Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson
hair and makeup Jessa alvera production
assistants McKenna Waters and Ryan love
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture
faith family all of the things that are
really important to you so come join the
conversation